[Music]
evan is with us to start off this hour
in iowa hi evan welcome to the ramsay
show
hi dave and george uh it's an honor to
speak with you both thanks for taking my
call and thanks so much for all you do
to help people well thank you what's up
uh so i uh about two years ago i started
to get after my debt i started with 85
000
in student loan debt and right now today
i'm at 53 000.
um
and so after kind of getting on board
well definitely getting on board with
your principles about six months ago
um i realized that the mutual fund i
have of uh thousand dollars i need to
cash out
um i cashed out five thousand of that at
the end of this past year
uh leaving me fifteen left in that
mutual fund and i was kind of waiting to
see
um to get closer to the end of the
student loan pause to take the remainder
of that out but it's starting to dwindle
these past couple weeks with everything
that's going on
in the world and so i guess i'm just my
question is
should i pull it out right now it's at
13 000 or should i try to see if it's
going to go back up and recoup some of
the some of that loss
does that make sense
well if i'm in your shoes there's some
things i can control and one of those
things is not the economy and the stock
market but i can control paying down the
student loan debt as much as i can right
now and so i'm cashing it out because i
just don't know the future
okay here's the swing evan okay
the the likelihood that that student
loan goes up 10
in just a few months is very low
10 in a year maybe that wouldn't be
unusual but 10 in a couple of months
would be highly unusual ten percent of
thirteen thousand is thirteen hundred
dollars
we don't have a thirteen hundred dollar
discussion we have a fifty three
thousand dollar problem
thirteen hundred dollars one way or the
other does not make or break this
discussion
okay so what happens is i have the
feeling that's what you're gonna say
yeah i do this all the time and that's
why i recognize it when other people do
it here's what we do
we start running math numbers and we
start looking at percentages and we
forget to look
and say okay there's a fifty three
thousand dollar problem
and i'm over here trying to manipulate
four dollars somewhere
or thirteen hundred dollars an
insignificant amount of money compared
to the size of the problem
in order to somehow get an edge on this
problem where if i had taken that same
level of energy and said okay i'm gonna
cut my budget i'm gonna work six jobs
i'm gonna not go out to eat i'm not
going on vacation i'm going to
completely focus on this problem and i'm
going to punch this 53 000 in the face
so many times that it just falls over
dead then
you know that's the deal and so the
secret sauce here evan is your
commitment and your energy and your
visceral response to this debt
that is 95 of your solution
five percent of your solution is math
manipulation
and so that that's what
i forget that because i'm a math nerd
and i'm always going to fix it with math
and most the time it's not math it's
dave
he's the problem on paper it looks great
but then life happens so here's what i'm
seeing on paper if it helps you out
you've already paid off thirty two
thousand dollars in debt yeah if you
cash out the mutual fund you're now down
to thirty eight no no you went from
eighty five to fifty three so that's
that's about a thirty two
oh yeah he goes down to thirty eight i'm
sorry so then you go down to thirty
eight now i can see the light at the end
of the tunnel because he goes yeah i've
done this before three thousand dollars
a month you're done in a year boom boom
and you start to go yeah yeah the
momentum and then you start finding that
money you say you know i go get that
different thing i
i change this around and that's how it
works so
that's the weird thing about personal
finance is it's usually not a math
problem
it's usually a focus an intentionality
problem
a sacrifice problem
a
commitment problem
uh it usually falls in those categories
and that that's what changes everything
so this that's just a great call evan
it's a really really
good question because it exposes the
things that most of us do where we place
our
our energies are our true you know we
that we
we think something's a solution that's
not
and so it's like okay i you know i'm
going to refinance my credit cards from
18 down to 14. okay how much do you have
a credit card a thousand dollars you
just four dollars
sometimes you just changed your life you
know that's just you didn't say you
might why why did you can't even pay for
the stamp
to fix this i mean you probably wouldn't
use a stamp but oh my gosh you know i
mean it's just that that's wow but this
is a good it's a good point because with
the stock market investing when you're
up five percent ten percent you go well
i gotta keep waiting and you start to
get a little bit a little bit greedy
like you're in vegas you're like well
i'm up i'm doing well let's keep riding
this thing out and see how it goes but
that's not the problem the problem is
you you're not making the extra percent
the problem is you're 53 000 in debt and
the payments are eating your life
exactly so you got it evan you got this
and i'll you you and i could tell by
talking to you that you got it
and so i i predict good things for you
call us back with a debt free screening
it's coming it's coming your way that's
very cool
personal finance
is 80 behavior
it's only 20 head knowledge
that means that
here's how you become wealthy
it's 80 behavior
it's only 20 head knowledge the
mathematics of becoming a millionaire
sixth grade level sixth grade level it's
called compound interest
it's not a calculus formula it's not a
trigonometry formula the pythagorean
theorem is not involved
what a waste of learning that was the
twerp in my mirror however
is the biggest issue if i can get that
boy to behave he can be skinny and rich
you'll get there we'll get there you got
you're one for two
too soon
you look great you're fired jordan